has there been in the sort of purist
boxing community
i imagine there must have been some
pushback it's seen as like this noble
art
the sweet science where's your stance on
this do you think that these youtube
boxing events should be allowed
i i think if they are youtubers against
youtubers and they have at a camp and
they've got themselves a license
i sorry there's no what was what's the
difference between someone
off the street who wants to start to
become a boxer i mean as long as they
have a reasonable age they get licensed
absolutely go for it go for it i mean
it's great
but then box people on an obvious level
so
a youtuber finding another youtuber as
long as they've
done the training and everything and i
was
i was fortunate or unfortunate enough to
have to wake up with my son and watch
the uh
was it ksi against um against paul
fight i mean listen
as i said in my teens i hang around gyms
i've seen all sorts yeah
i i fought myself i was a terror i had
two left hands you know and
unfortunately i'm not southpaw so you
know i've seen
boxing at all levels and you know it was
it was
it was entertaining i thought i thought
actually ksi was quite
athletic i think that below the pools
are clearly as well
but you know it's it's obviously levels
off floyd mayweather
you know i mean that's like me saying
yeah i had a bit played a bit of tennis
back in the day i'm gonna go better i'm
gonna do a three month camp and i'm
challenging you
you know roger federer and me you know
we'll do it down uh down
down the region's part we'll book a call
that's you know i mean you know
seriously that that
that part it's entertainment though if
they want to do it then do it but
it's not boxing you know but listening
makes probably makes a lot of
number sense but what's the difference
between
that a youtuber fighting a youtuber and
a youtuber fighting a boxer then is your
concern for the safety of the youtuber
or is it something more kind of
sacred about the fact that mayweather
shouldn't be going down to the level of
someone that's just a youtuber
i think that i think that
first of all it's so unrealistic
that unless that boxer and this has been
the case mayweather's case
unless he toys with him and i don't know
throws throws his punches at 30 you know
um i think it's bloody dangerous
i think it's bloody dangerous i i think
that
it's not it's not tennis the example i
use with federer was a bit of a laugh
but it's it's a thing that if if you've
ever stood in a ring
and and you've i've been i've been in a
ring with
as i've mentioned before there's a as a
terrible
gym fire that's how i would describe
myself i wouldn't call myself an amateur
there's a terrible gym fighter
who liked a bit of a tear up as a kid um
i remember being in a ring with um with
my old coach actually
he was he was a pro he was it was
nothing special he was a decent thing
but
listen when i say nothing special it's
still a great credit to it was a it was
a british level pro
had to retire with sort of medical
reasons early and became a trainer
uh clay o'shea great great trainer and
i remember him sparring women it wasn't
even
he was toying with me and what do you
understand it is the sweet science if
you can box properly
you won't come near me you won't be able
to even land
lever in my area yeah
and i remember standing oh in my right
you know i was i was 19 20 years old
lots of testosterone in me and i was
i was giving it a real go and i was
following my right i just remember him
just
moving and dropping me with a with a
body shot and the body shot for people
who don't know
is aimed at the liver which has the
direct impact of cutting the oxygen to
the brain about two seconds later so you
stand
and then bomb you go to the floor and it
was
i was like whoa okay
that that prose aspect of a pro contract
is definitely gone
um probably didn't have that had a
terrible hangover from the night before
but never certainly felt it and and it
was my memory you know and
that has always stayed with me so when
you see these journeymen in the ring and
you think oh my rubbish yeah
that journeyman if you stood with him
you wouldn't get near him right
so to say as and once again credit to
the youtubers i've been very harsh in
other interviews about but i do
give him credit for the training they
put in because i mean that
ksi wasn't was in the condition of his
life that paul like i said
it seems to be you know he's what he is
i think he's a bit of a knob when he
when he when he goes and talks every
disrespects fighters i think that's
disgusting and i think he deserves to be
put in his place
but the realism of him
and floyd mayweather who is once again
not my
ex british level pro trainer and you
know
this is floyd mayweather this is
arguably right now definitely
the greatest defensive boxer of all time
so what on earth
are you doing in a ring with him in your
in your what is his second pro fight and
by the way
just just to put this on paper he lost
his first pro fight against ksi
so so he's got a record of norton one
and he's fighting the greatest defensive
boxer of all time
okay ricky hatton by the way ricky
hatton
a legend a great fighter
got knocked the [ __ ] out
by mayweather now you tell me
logan paul and ricky hatton never been
covered in the boxery
nothing apart from they both have two
legs that's it
there's no other similarity they don't
even have the same hands yeah
they don't even have the same hands so
logan paul
give it a go don't
mouth off about fighters when you are a
youtuber
let's get that straight you are a
youtuber
but you're very good at youtubing but
maybe beat another youtuber first
and and and you know then you know then
call out
i don't know call out the local area
champion
you know maybe you know the greatest of
all time
and then talk crap about him as well so
it's but once again
i get it it's for business and it's fine
i just hope that floyd
has one hand tape behind his back at the
time
and floyd has the other hand tape behind
his head at the time
he'll still win then it might be a fair
fight he still wins because the other
way if he wanted to wouldn't lay
one glove on him even without hands so
you know so how do i see it i think i
think it's great that these guys are
they are making an effort to train it's
not like they go in there and just you
know
they do put that they do put the time in
the gym and that's all good
but they should be fighting at levels
which is entertaining for us you know
i'm not saying that i was
super entertained now as a purist by
watching ksi logan paul
but i respected it i respected it and i
let my son watch it i let him
pay his five-year-old in pocket money
for it you know
yeah but if it brings that that younger
audience in exactly
um i imagine that for you guys down the
line where are they going to be if they
watch
mayweather logan paul and they love it
and then they think well actually this
boxing stuff's all right
and then in they go to their local gym
and then maybe they start paying for
your pay-per-views
because they get into the more pure side
of stuff i think what you've identified
there is
it's kind of what everyone has in the
back of their mind which is that the
gulf in ability between
anyone that hasn't been a boxer since
they were a kid and dedicated their
entire life to it
and even the worst pro is probably
absolutely massive and we don't we don't
really realize that because
obviously when you see mayweather
pacquiao they both make it look so
effortless
but we might see probably for the first
time i think someone who's like a proper
noob you know like a normie stepping
into the ring with as you say someone
who's
essentially a ghost yeah and
but once again i think even
even conor mcgregor mayweather was it
was a fast
yeah i mean it was a fast that sold
a shitload of pay-per-views yeah
it sold and and it was a spec and i i
watched it
but i mean conor's a great fighter in
the in the terms
fighting you know he's a he's a mixed
martial ass
uh martial arts
mixed martial arts expert and and he's
and he's let's let's face it he's he's
been the face of the ufc for the last
five years you know um
win or lose you know don't matter you
know it's conor mcgregor you know
he's the most recognizable face in the
history of the ufc
by a mile by a mile and
the only probably actually probably the
only fighter i would say that has
transgressed beyond the brand of those
three letters
you know he's the only one if he walked
down oxford street who everyone would
pick out
george from pierre you could argue back
it back a few years but
when he walked down the street i don't
think he would get stopped by a mob
mcgregor certainly would alone by the
way he walks um
but now i'm digressing from the question
so
how do i see i once again i refer to
that fight because that is a fight
between a great fighter
and a great boxer and it was in a way an
interesting spectacle
did did mayweather let him have a few
rounds
to make it more interesting i'm pretty
sure he did you think i'm sorry
i'm pretty sure he did mayweather is
he's a genius
you know he is he's an absolute genius
in a ring
uh there's not been no fighter like him
ever ever
um not in terms of being exciting going
forward but he
i mean he developed the shoulder roll he
developed the shoulder roll which
if anyone doesn't know what a shoulder
roll is it's when you lift his shoulder
up
almost as a third hand to protect your
chin you know
he would ride punches with shoulders i
mean you know he did things in the
defensively so but this was against
opposition like oscar de la hoya like
ricky hatton i just mentioned
like canelo alvarez i mean he schooled
canelo alvarez yeah and canelo alvarez
wasn't a baby then by the way
he was an up and comer but he wasn't a
baby this is the greatest fight on the
planet at the moment canelo alvarez
and mayweather schooled him but now
mayweather knows always it's a 50-50
against
er against logan paul
[Music]